.
>> Sean: IF WE DO THAT, THINGS
WILL GET BETTER.
DAN BONGINO, AS ALWAYS,
THANK YOU.
NOW SHIFTING GEARS TO THE SWAMP
IN D.C. WHERE SENATOR LINDSEY
GRAHAM, STANDING UP TO THE BIDEN
OPEN BORDERS AMNESTY AGENDA.
HE IS SAYING THESE EFFORTS TO
SNEAK AMNESTY PACKETS INTO THE
SO-CALLED HUMAN INFRASTRUCTURE
PACKAGE IS THE DUMBEST IDEA IN
HISTORY OF THE SENATE.
AND THAT'S NOT ALL BECAUSE
SENATOR GRAHAM IS ALSO STANDING
UP FOR CHICK-FIL-A AFTER
APPARENT EFFORTS TO BAN IT FROM
NOTRE DAME.
HE JOINS US NOW.
SOUTH CAROLINA SENATOR, LINDSEY
GRAHAM.
OKAY.
YOU'LL ARE WITH ME BECAUSE YOU
AND I HAVE HAD MANY DISCUSSIONS,
EVEN YEARS BACK DEBATES OVER THE
BORDERS.
SECURE THE BORDER FIRST AND THAT
HAS NOT HAPPENED.
WE NOW HAVE NEARLY 200,000
PEOPLE A MONTH.
THE ANSWER IS SIMPLE IN MY MIND.
>> RIGHT.
YEAH, IT IS.
I'VE BEEN DEALING WITH ILLEGAL
IMMIGRATION FOR 15 YEARS.
POLICIES THAT INCENTIVIZE
ILLEGAL IMMIGRATION, YOU WILL
GET MORE OF IT.
IF A POLICY DETERS ILLEGAL
IMMIGRATION, YOU WILL GET LESS.
THE DUMBEST IDEA IN ALL OF
WASHINGTON WOULD BE TO GRANT
AMNESTY IN AN INFRASTRUCTURE
BILL WITHOUT FIRST SECURING THE
BORDER.
YOU WOULD HAVE AN INVASION
BEYOND WHAT YOU HAVE TODAY.
IF WE LEGALIZED 100,000 PEOPLE
OR A MILLION PEOPLE IN THE
INFRASTRUCTURE BILL, IT WOULD BE
A RUN ON OUR BORDERS BECAUSE
EVERYBODY WOULD GET THE MESSAGE
THAT THEY ARE LEGALIZING PEOPLE
IN AMERICA.
LET'S GO AND LET'S GO NOW.
YOU HAVE TO SECURE THE BORDER
BEFORE YOU GRANT ONE PERSON
LEGAL STATUS.
IF YOU DON'T, YOU WILL LOSE
CONTROL OF AMERICA, OF OUR
SOVEREIGNTY.
>> Sean: WELL, AND THE AMNESTY
BEHIND ALL OF THIS IS TRYING TO
BE PART OF THESE BIPARTISAN
DISCUSSIONS.
DEMOCRATS THOUGH, IN MANY WAYS,
I SEE THEM SAYING, OH, WE'VE GOT
A BIPARTISAN BILL ON HUMAN
INFRASTRUCTURE.
AND THEN THEY WILL USE
RECONCILIATION TO GET EVERYTHING
ELSE THEY WANT.
DO YOU WANT TO ALLOW THAT TO
HAPPEN?
>> WELL, SO I'VE SAID IT A
COUPLE OF DAYS AGO.
IF THEY PUT AMNESTY IN THE THREE
AND A HALF TRILLION DOLLAR
INFRASTRUCTURE BILL THAT'S GOT
NOTHING TO DO WITH
INFRASTRUCTURE, ITS BIG
GOVERNMENT, HIGHER TECH, IF THEY
PUT AMNESTY IN THAT BILL, I
WOULD TRY TO DENY THEM PASSING
THAT BILL.
A 50/50 SENATE.
THE VICE PRESIDENT DOESN'T
COUNT -- GO A LOT OF PEOPLE
PUSHED BACK TO ME, TO MY
REPUBLICAN COLLEAGUES.
WHAT ARE WE GOING TO DO IF THEY
LOAD OFF THE THREE AND A HALF
TRILLION, 5 TRILLION
INFRASTRUCTURE BILL WITH MAIL-IN
VOTING AND ANIMISTIC?
WHAT IS OUR RESPONSE?
IF YOU DON'T LIKE MY IDEA, COME
UP WITH ONE OF YOUR OWN.
IF WE DON'T FIGHT BACK AS HARD
AS WE CAN, THEY ARE DESTROYING
THE SENATE.
GOING TO LEAD TO AN ILLEGAL
IMMIGRANT INVASION LIKE WE'VE
NEVER SEEN IN THE HISTORY OF THE
COUNTRY.
SO MY IDEA IS DO ANYTHING AND
EVERYTHING POSSIBLE TO STOP THIS
BEFORE IT HAPPENS.
LET THE DEMOCRATS KNOW THAT IF
YOU PUT LEGALIZING ILLEGAL
IMMIGRANTS IN THE RECONCILIATION
BILL, THEN WE AS REPUBLICANS
WILL USE EVERYTHING AVAILABLE TO
US.
>> Sean: EVERYBODY THAT WASHES
THE SHOW PROBABLY KNOWS I DON'T
SUPPORT BOYCOTTS.
NEVER HAVE AND I'M NEVER GOING
TO OR CANCEL CULTURE.
BUT I DO SUPPORT BOYCOTTS.
I LIKE WHAT YOU SAID ABOUT
CHICK-FIL-A.
I LOVE CHICK-FIL-A.
CHICK-FIL-A, I LOVE IT.
ABSOLUTELY AMAZING.
SO OKAY, THEY WANT TO HURT
CHICK-FIL-A.
I'M GOING TO SUPPORT
JUST BECAUSE I LIKE IT.
THOUGHTS?
>> NOTRE DAME IS A GREAT
UNIVERSITY.
YOU HAD A HANDFUL OF NOTRE DAME
STUDENTS AND FACULTY PETITIONING
THE UNIVERSITY NOT TO ALLOW
CHICK-FIL-A ON CAMPUS.
IT'S THE NUMBER ONE FAST FOOD
COMPANY IN AMERICA.
IT'S GOOD FOOD, GOOD SERVICE AT
A REASONABLE PRICE.
A CATHOLIC FAMILY.
THEY ARE RELIGIOUS PEOPLE.
HERE IS MY STATEMENT TO THE
FACULTY AND STUDENTS AT
NOTRE DAME.
YOU DON'T HAVE THE RIGHT TO DENY
SOMEONE SERVICE BECAUSE THEY
HAVE SOME RELIGIOUSLY HELD
BELIEFS.
THAT'S VERY BAD AND VERY
DANGEROUS FOR AMERICA.
WE'VE GOT TO SPEAK UP.
IF THEY PUT AMNESTY IN THE
INFRASTRUCTURE BILL, IF YOU
DON'T LIKE MY IDEAS AS A
REPUBLICAN, YOU BETTER COME UP
WITH ONE OF YOUR OWN, BECAUSE WE
WON'T SURRENDER AND JUST BE RUN
OVER.
I'M NEVER GOING TO LET THAT
HAPPEN.
WHEN A COMPANY LIKE CHICK-FIL-A
IS ATTACKED BECAUSE THEY WANT TO
ACT ON THEIR FAITH AND WE DON'T
STAND BEHIND THEM, THEN SOME BUT
HE WILL COME AFTER OUR FAITH.
>> Sean: THAT'S WILL HAVE
INSIDE.
THE WAY, I WILL GO TO
CHICK-FIL-A, BUT IF THE LINE IS
LIKE IT USUALLY IS, DOWN THE
BLOCK COME AROUND THE CORNER,
I'M NOT GOING TO WAIT.
I'M ONLY GOING IN IF IT'S A
SHORT LINE.